welcome back to the realest podcast
in the dunya the three muslims you're
joined here with myself bahad and
brother rami assalam alaikum bro
how you doing today man
good could be better bro i'm still
getting used to discord because we can't
see the live chat so i can't really
address anyone but maybe there's
probably two or three people watching us
bro let's be honest right now no there's
actually 571 and we just started
alhamdulillah which is amazing
guys please drop a like and drop a
subscribe if you're not subscribed
and
without further ado let's go in
all right
so
we begin by praising allah the most
gracious the most merciful the most just
the one who sent
with the truth the prophet
muhammad the best of mankind and example
for everyone peace and blessings be upon
him
today's live stream i think the main
message of this is just to
basically send a message to young don
there's no point in going back and forth
in live streams and videos and little
echo chambers
come discuss with us
let's talk
this back and forth stuff is childish if
you want to continue doing it continue
doing it whatever
we want to talk we've invited you three
maybe four times now
so right now we're to make an
announcement for a live stream i'm going
to let 5 get into that
to which we are inviting you to join us
on fire take away bro
guys i wanted to say boys but a lot of
sisters watching mello bless you guys
and girls tuning in
and we wanted to say this friday this is
going to be the most live
stream that we have had
in quite a while we're bringing on
brother hamza
andreas zortsis i know a lot of people
know who hamza zortos is he is an
intellectual and academic theologian
he
talks about islam science religion
theism
the mirage of atheism right he's working
on a phd right now and his dissertation
is on the quran and science specifically
um he got in touch with me this morning
bro and we were just talking about
what's going on with all this and and
the nonsense of the islamophobic
youtubers
like young don straight up and he wanted
to say that you know there's a lot of
lies being told there's a lot of
misinformation and we need to refute it
academically and intellectually as
muslims
um
one thing i wanted to address too is bro
we don't want to go on streams every day
do back and forth delete videos do name
calling we don't do any of this bro
i'm not saying that's what young don is
up to but i'm not saying that either
i've seen a lot of videos get taken down
and bro you're right this is childish
this is immature this is clown behavior
there's no there's no need for this bro
and you know i want to hear your
thoughts so far and
i do want to go into the whole market
and economy of the islamophobes
100 inshallah so there's a few people
saying that there's a bit of uh lag it's
just the
uploading it to youtube i don't know why
maybe my upload speed is a little bit
laggy right now nothing i can do about
it but insha allah this will be a short
stream anyway just to talk about a few
of the things that don said in reaction
to our initial live stream uh in his
livestream yesterday um
other than that again we are inviting
him to come discuss with us on friday
with hamza zorces
this back and forth stuff is just
useless childish and you're going to see
that by the way you guys are going to
see it because we're going to react to
some of his rebuttals to what we
mentioned with sheikh man
is there anything else you want to
mention before we get into it
yeah bro um
i guess we can talk about the the whole
this is an important thing too it's not
going to take too long for me to discuss
it but
this industry right this economy this
market
of islamophobes whether it be apost
whether it be david wood whether it be
hatun all these youtubers that you and i
know very clearly right
this whole industry is based on what if
i was to ask you do you think it's based
on huck bro do you think it's based on
truth or do you think it's based on lies
misinformation misinterpretations of the
quran mistranslation so on what do you
think yeah 100 is based on
misinterpretation miscommunication
and um
not even miscommunication they're
communicating what they want to but
misinterpretation of the message and a
lot of them actually a lot of it's for
money a lot of these people like apos
and david what they're making a lot of
money from like you know maybe hindu
nationalists and other people who hate
islam
so there's that for them too
bro bro think about it if these people
didn't spew their nonsense if these
people didn't create their cult-like
following which hates islam
out of ignorance or even arrogance if
they didn't do that would they get their
bread would they put food on the table
they wouldn't bro the reality is they
wouldn't most of these people if not all
of them have patreons have youtube have
donations that paypal have all these
things and yes a lot of muslim channels
do too but i want you guys to think
about it we don't make anything out of
this though like if if more people
convert islam alhamdulillah we're happy
with that if more people don't convert
to islam then
at the end of the day bro may allah have
mercy on them but if you look at these
youtubers they're going to make a lot
more money and for this market to exist
they need to keep doing what they're
doing even if they've been debut debated
refuted countless times bro
hums zortas has debated a lot of them
right when you look at apus he's been
destroyed multiple times academically on
debates he's had meltdowns he's been
destroyed when you look at david wood
he's been destroyed too so it breaks my
heart when i look like look at you know
go on twitter i see people like don
saying oh i spent the whole day watching
david what i spent the whole day
watching apost anyone wants to convert
to islam make sure you watch these
youtubers first like no bro at the end
of the day if you want to learn
neuroscience you're not going to go
learn neuroscience from uh you know
baker if you're trying to learn uh
astronomy you're not gonna go to a
chemist you know what i mean same thing
with islam bro if you want to learn
islam
you can't just go for you know to any
muslim
you got to go to muslims that are
preaching and spreading the deen
properly right so similarly at the day
when you're going to ex-muslims and this
is a this is a sub-topic we don't want
to get too much into that because i do
want you to finish your point
when you look at ex-muslims bro it can
boil down to one of a couple categories
right either they were raised in a very
oppressive and strict household and
emotionally they want to leave the dean
and the parents used islam
as a means to justify them being overly
controlling and i'm not talking about
within means i'm talking about outside
of means right without any means um or
they emotionally want to let go of this
idea of their being a god and they want
to indulge in dhonia pleasures bro in a
guilt-free manner right there could be
other ones where it's like they know
that they're going to make a lot of
money
doing haram jobs or whatever so at the
end of the day you got to realize that
this industry this economy this market
it exists for a reason
monetary is one of the biggest
influences there is
and at the end of the day it breaks my
heart when i see people that don't know
any better they go on young don's stream
they see someone like apos on right and
they're just like wow look i didn't know
there were these scientific errors in
the quran which
it's translations bro it's not even
heirs or i didn't know this is the truth
about oh look here's someone that
was born into islam
but then they eventually left yeah so
for me
as a layman as a non-muslim this is not
me by the way this is like their
psychology why would i want to even go
into islam then why waste my time
because if i do what if i end up leaving
like this guy and they don't know any
better so maybe they won't even look
into it yeah 100
and um i mean just think about that kind
of that kind of belief that oh look this
person left islam it must not be true
are you using this one individual as you
know the measuring stick for what truth
is are you going to follow everything
they say and do because because one
person left islam or one maybe even if
one person joined islam all of a sudden
now is the truth
i think that has to be the most
redundant and unintellectual thing
somebody could do unless they actually
like for us with the prophet peace be
upon him take him as someone who is
the um
truth
not arbitrator but deliverer from allah
from god we use the quran we use the
prophet peace be upon him and they tell
us what is true and what we should and
shouldn't do and we obey allah as we are
his creation and
this is not meant to be any insults
towards young dawn i saw his stream
he was a lot of the time and he does
this a lot a lot of christians do
actually they use a lot of emotion
and not so much a lot of proper logical
arguments you guys are gonna see it you
guys will see it and for the people who
are worried about like the you know
scientific arguments and that stuff we
will cover it all on friday with a
someone who has a phd in the philosophy
of science we will cover all of that and
someone who's been
giving dawah for many many years maybe
longer than i've been alive allah adam
online socially so on and so forth and
they're going to discuss all that stuff
with us and you guys will see a trailer
of that
on uh wednesday insha allah two days
from now today's monday yeah bro
wednesday we're just dropping a little
bit of a teaser with thomas ortiz it's
not going to be the live stream guys
remember the live stream is one friday
at 6 00 p.m eastern standard time 11 p.m
uk time uh that's midnight for germany
technically saturday at that point but
yeah 6 p.m eastern standard time
on friday so it's going to be basically
30 minutes before now present time on
friday once again and you'll get a
little bit of a teaser with hums
resources on wednesday links in the
description guys to even find out who
hums of zorces is some of his work some
of his debates and rami bro take it away
yeah so to all the people that are
saying young don is live now with uh
with apus i know i saw like four seconds
of it i know he's live it doesn't really
matter to be honest apostles at the end
of the day is not someone who even
shares his own beliefs so the fact that
he's bringing him on for the sole
purpose of taking islam down is really
funny especially with people like david
wood who's a christian allegedly and
apos who's an atheist 99 percent of the
contents on islam which shows you what
that even people who hate islam their
life is still oriented around it still
based on it it's all they ever talk
about that's how they make their their
fame their fortune whatever is still
based on islam which is funny so um and
you know actually this the verse and the
quran
allah talks about people who kind of
change the scripture
you know with their own hands say this
is from allah that's kind of what
they're doing
they don't write it but they're
basically changing what allah says and i
think a more accurate verse is
surah al-imran i think chapter
chapter 3 verse 7 allah
he says are the people that are looking
to spread mischief they rely on
ambiguous verses in their false
interpretations that's exactly what
allah says that's exactly what dawn did
as you're going to see very soon that's
exactly what david what does that's
exactly what a plus does that's exactly
what christian prince does all these
people and well it's funny you know he
is this is not to be disrespectful it's
just a bit funny
that he praises and
he kind of boasts about the fact that he
has these people's contacts like so what
what like go watch the debate between
david wood muhammad hijab watch the
debate between david wood and apost and
uh
and danny hakiku
against him and any other muslim frankly
watched the debate between apos which uh
and uh danny hakikuchu which apos even
said recently all right actually i think
a while ago that he admits he lost that
debate
i want to take this moment in charlotte
talk about some super chats
uh i need to get better at reading them
ali brother ali says they make money
bashing islam you guys are amazing may
allah bless you happy thank you for the
super chat seventy dollars five dollars
he's always coming through with that
support bro
more than once
brother says i will admit don made a
good point when he came to hadith and
muslim hadith the rest of his points
were removed please check your community
post
please check your community post what
like the comments in it you have to be
more uh
inshallah no worries we'll get to that
inshallah we will get to that i think
it's in the beginning of the stream i uh
saw that as well and then
uh
ace i think just gave a super chat
without any text mello bless you so i
think it's best that we just get into it
to be honest
by the way i was speaking to sheikh
bhattaslim and also subord earlier today
yeah and both of them were telling me
that you know when you deal with
christianity is
the whole theology and i don't say this
in a disrespectful way i know i want you
guys to pay attention to what i'm saying
right now i say this in a very pious way
when you look at christianity
theologically is illogical
the trinity itself is illogical it's a
very emotional thing yeah and when you
look jesus died for my sins so i can
have eternal whatever and i don't have
to worry about anything it's a very
emotional thing
i would love to believe in a fairy tale
like that bro but it's not logical bro
you know uh and i don't want to by the
way just before the haram police come
after me so what i'm trying to say is
fundamentally if there's no logic it
doesn't matter how much logic or
rationale you throw their way at the end
of the day we gotta stand by what we
stand by and understand that we can
educate the masses what they do with
that that's on them bro 100
100
let me um
let me read this one
super chat i think it's a bit funny from
brother edward snipes i hope i said that
right apus is currently debating don
ellowell so i went against him how would
you guys respond to apostle's claim that
god is a man-made concept a man-made
concept
firstly i want this is something i think
it's a good learning moment for everyone
here
when anyone makes a claim you don't need
to refute it you would only need to
refute the evidence they provide because
an argument is a claim with evidence if
i claim god exists necessarily and
someone claims god is a man-made
concept or constructed belief
both of our claims have zero credibility
like the view of just me and you talking
uh
it's not that big of a deal is it i just
shared my screen this won't be long this
won't be long don't worry okay guys
so
it's
it's they both have the same level of
intellectual uh intellectual authority
they're both claims with no evidence for
him to claim that he has to prove it
and we can demonstrate and i don't know
if he's been in a debate with whether
god exists or not which i think he would
honestly lose horribly
but if we were to argue that god does or
doesn't exist we would fall to the
contingency argument you would find that
infinite regression cannot exist you
can't have a world of only possible
existences and that would be the
deductive argument but you have no even
logical argument that that god does not
exist at least in the very basic
definition of god so i think that's a
good learning point for everyone don
claimed a lot of things so what
i can claim a lot of things fired can
claim a lot of things unless it's backed
up with evidence it's fairly meaningless
so let's get
into this oh can i tell you something do
you remember that that reel that we
posted with uh gabriel on the podcast
he said that a lot of these people think
that the truth has to be something that
i agree with
and i'm gonna say this again for the
people that in the back that didn't hear
it the truth has to be something that i
agree with
this is one of the biggest logical
fallacies
philosophically speaking today and i see
so many people fall into that oh just
because i don't agree with it means that
it's not true who says the truth has to
be something that you agree with yeah
i'm 100
and i think that's where some people
like
entertain you you know may allah guide
him to islam but i think people like
entertain that's where they fall short
uh i think honestly maybe sneakers a
little bit better in this regard but uh
andrew tate what is he appreciating he's
doing a live with uh soon too who
sneakers doing alive with april soon bro
okay that's gonna be this is gonna be
fun inshallah hopefully also a muslim
someone can get on but regardless
someone like andrew tate
he
he praises islam for things that he
agrees with and actually a lot of the
time he misconstrues islam in the belief
and preaches a version of slam that is
not true because he agrees with it and
then praises islam for it
that's kind of a good example of someone
who wants to believe it or thinks it's
the best bet in the stock market
religiously because they agree with it
already but again you're just making
yourself the
measuring stick for truth but with that
being said inshaallah
let's just jump into this uh video and
start talking about some of the things
that he uh says bismillah things and
actions the prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him and we stick to
the true message we still worship the
way of the prophet
showed us to worship
yeah i don't know
and
i mean when you look at christianity
like let's look i apologize for the
volume i know it's very sad uh and low i
hope it's better this time insha'allah
it's on max so i hope you can just bear
with it
what pre-day's christian let's look at
judaism let's look at you know the torah
what was satan's mission satan's mission
was to get them to worship other than
god himself
that's why when they crossed the red sea
and god saved them from firaoun and
pharaoh they made the golden calf and
they worshipped it obviously they were
rebuked for that in the quran at least
moses was very mad at them for that when
he got back and saw that
so if you look at satan's mission from
the old testament his goal is to get you
to worship other than god when you get
to christianity you see
jesus who worshiped god who obeyed the
mosaic law
and after he passes away 300 years later
by the way comes the
indoctrination of the trinity that we
have today co-equal co eternal persons
within the trinity jesus fully god
filling man all that stuff and they end
up worshiping amen so would you say that
jesus
or sorry would you say that satan
failed in his mission to get people to
worship other than god when you guys are
now worshipping not just
the the father which we would say is god
no problem but the son a man and the
holy spirit as well which we would say
is the angel gabriel and now you see
that islam came with the same message
that jesus originally had which we could
talk about later which religion is more
in line and which religion is farther
from what
god has sent previously
look at the ten commandments here okay
so i want you guys
to
just take a moment to digest
what i said in that clip there
let me just open this back up i want you
guys to take a second and digest what i
said in that clip i said
that satan's gold in the old testament
was to
get people to worship other than god one
people are now worshiping a man and the
holy spirit
in christianity
three
in islam we call to worship one god
alone and just god himself
so in conclusion
which religion
follows what was originally sent in
judaism and which religion goes against
that and actually falls into what satan
wanted to be done which is worship other
than god that's what i said
now let's go and see
how he responds
his first first commandment is hear o
israel your lord is one and i'm going to
review all of that towards the end of
the video i i want to just play out this
video um however islam is filled with
contradictions it is filled with
contradictions first and foremost islam
verifies the validity of the gospels and
of the torah i don't want to jump the
gun and get to that so his response to
everything i just said about satan's
mission and them worshiping a man uh he
responds to that which saying the that
islam has contradictions the quran has
contradictions
where is the logical link between what i
said and what he's saying now and if
anyone says that i'm leaving parts out
or anything
i'll play the rest of it and you can see
what he jumps to next yeah because i
have a pretty nice presentation laid out
where this will be covered however this
is simply untrue the the quran is filled
with all kinds of contradictions the
most important of the one is the fact
that it verifies the validity of the
bible and then it verifies the validity
of the gospels and then proceeds to
contradict the gospels which came before
the quran
i have you know that
hundreds of years before the quran was
written the gospels were written
and so
the quran came much later in the gospels
verifies the validity of the gospels and
i'm going to give you the actual surah
that says that you know i'm again i'm
again into detail later when i do my
presentation
but
here here you go if you want a little
sample piece
if you want a little sample okay you
know because i know not everything yeah
i was actually do you give me 30 seconds
i want to show the verse he's going to
pull down the string and then i was
going to pause it just like 10 seconds
everybody's going to stay for the entire
presentation
so
here so you could see that in response
to what i said he pulls up these verses
from the quran and he tries to argue
that the quran says that the bible is
true and intact and it never says
corrupt and all that stuff that's how he
responded to
the point that was made
so fired bro
bro i wanted to say that i'm sure a lot
of people know the reality and the
refutation of this but you know the
the scripture is sent to musa alayhi
salaam the scripture says
these are this is not the old testament
new testament bro this is not because
everyone knows this bro this is common
sense but i just wanted to say bro can
we give a huge shout out to don to young
clown
for literally making a powerpoint
presentation bro
like my man literally made up i haven't
made those in school bro but shout out
bro
let's let's let's try and keep it and
this is to everyone in the comments as
well let's try and keep it with no
insults
that doesn't you know really get
anywhere
um
that's true
and i want to take this time to mention
some super chats uh
this guy's name is
i-r-a-m-i irami or irami don thinks he
exposes islam all he's doing is
regurgitating the same claims and lies
that have been debunked and those hate
preachers and semephobes have been
exposed more times than once 100 and if
you know that's a claim to prove it go
watch those debates you'll see it for
yourself
um
muhammad says lmao brother this should
be easy for you if you are right you
should be able to find translation
before
i'm sorry maybe that's the type of
hubble prove that i don't know what that
means bro um but i agree with the first
part if islam is true christianity is
true you should be able to demonstrate
it and any lie should be
basically you should be able to prove it
false
as long as you know empirical grounds
for it
the approach with people like him need
to be different his naivety blindness
can't humble or sorry can't handle such
shock he felt when he got jumped
bro um may allah bless you we didn't
jump him to be honest
i know he likes to make it seem like we
jumped him but all of us who were silent
i think i said maybe two sentences
but
i spoke bro after getting shared with
manon yeah i i i said that he's coping
bro he's coping hard it's okay it is
what it is i mean people can see for
themselves you know i said two sentences
it was all-shaykh man talking to him he
i think he was just experiencing
cognitive dissonance and he was upset
that he couldn't really answer it
and um actually i think all of us could
have jumped on him and actually
intellectually jumped him five on one
but we didn't we didn't we bro i wanted
to but out of respect for sheikh man you
know he's my elder he's he's uh our
teacher i didn't say anything it's it's
him uh and young dawn and i was the one
actually who mentioned that there's five
about to be five muslims and one
christian we're all going to be
respectful of that and we were so i
don't know why he wants to go ahead and
kind of jump to that
bro you're right we learned a lot from
sheikh with man may allah bless him
and uh elevate him bro and grant him the
highest ranks of jannah but what i did
want to say was
at the end of the day i know nico is
going to make some you know clickbaity
titles like 5v1 quran versus bible nah
bro if you and and we didn't delete
anything guys you can watch the videos
yourself it was literally just shaykh
with man and don and that no one else
yeah but um let's get let's get back to
uh
the actual topic it's been 31 minutes we
don't want to go probably over an hour
this is supposed to be quick again
shouting out friday's live stream with
hamza zortsis we're inviting young don
to come be with us he made a whole
powerpoint presentation we're just
hoping he stands back by it and we'll
come and defend the claims that he made
with us
with hamza zortsis
we'll we will see inshallah this is an
invitation humbly respectfully
come talk with us insha allah and with
that being said
let's
go back to the main video here so
he pulls up two verses from the quran
and uh let's hear what he has to say
about it i'm gonna let y'all i'ma let
y'all just beat this for a second
surah 3
ayah 2-8 allah there is no god of
worship except for the ever-living all
sustaining he has revealed to you o
prophet the book in truth confirming
what came before it as he revealed the
torah and the gospel previously as a
guide for people and also revealed the
standard to distinguish between right
and wrong surely those who reject
allah's revelation will suffer a severe
torment for allah is almighty capable of
punishment
there you have it allah himself says
that he sent the torah and the gospel to
be a guide for people
okay surah 18 verse 27.
recite what has been revealed to you
from the book of your lord
none can change his words nor can you
find any refuge besides him let's
put that put that and i need to shift
gears right now i still feel like i'm
talking to muslims they're a lost cause
for most of them some of you might be
able to have your eyes open and i i
really pray to god that i am able to do
that or help that process
but let me shift gears i'm talking to
people who don't know about islam right
so this is what the quran says i mean
how can you talk to people who don't
know about islam when you yourself
didn't know about islam like two seconds
ago like it i find it a bit funny and
this is again not to be disrespectful
just think about it it's funny that what
two
three maybe four days ago he didn't know
anything about islam he came to learn
from us
and then in four days he knows so much
that he can automatically just debunk it
from a logical religious and scientific
perspective come on he just went to
islam haters got a bunch of arguments
because he has a preconceived notion
that christianity is true and that islam
is wrong and from the devil like he
claimed previously and he's going to
take whatever he can to argue that now i
want to talk about some of the claims
that he has already made
before i do that one brother mentioned
please look out for the comments and
don't ignore it like young dawn did i
will not do that inshallah i'll do my
best to keep up with the comments
there's a lot going 1300 people in here
and if i see anything that stands out in
sha allah will definitely jump on it but
he quotes the quran
where allah
he mentions that he sent the torah and
the injil now for some reason
young don makes the connection between
the torah and the old testament and the
injil and the new testament he
refers to it all as the bible oh god
sent the bible it doesn't say god sent
the bible they actually didn't even have
the bible translated into arabic at the
time of the prophet peace be upon him it
was translated one maybe 200 years after
the prophet peace upon him passed away
in islam was already spread
so what allah says is that he sent the
torah originally to moses and the gospel
originally to jesus what is the gospel
i'll tell you what it's not it's not the
gospel according to mark according to
matthew according to luke according to
john all of which who are anonymous
authors and just very conveniently named
mark matthew luke and john and
the authorship of the book
that's not what the angel is the injil
is whatever god sent originally to jesus
do we have that no we don't
and actually definitively we can never
know or have the original gospel of
jesus peace and blessings be upon him i
mentioned this book last time the five
gospels i won't go to it again you guys
can watch that streams what i say about
it and you can see most of the
manuscripts of the 9th century many
different things
empirically to show
that the bible that we have today is not
the original that was sent to moses or
the original that was sent to jesus so
when god says
that he sent the torah and the injil
he's referring to that which is original
now it's possible and most likely that
we have remnants of the originals and
what we have today but how do we
decipher between what is true and what
is false allah actually answers that in
the following verses from the ones that
he points out
allah he says that the quran is a
superiority
it's superior
to the other books and that's why the
quran is called the criterion because
they use it to decipher whatever is in
the older scripture
and that's why allah sent the quran then
he mentions then he mentions let's go
with this argument it falls short there
but let's go with this argument that
the bible is the word of god all of it
today the way we have it
and
god's word cannot be actually let me
retract not the way we have it but the
bible today whatever the bible
in some constellation is what god sent
he says
in he quotes in the quran the words of
allah kelliman to allah cannot be
changed and he says look the words of
god can't be changed so i can't change
the bible i can't change the torah or
the or the gospel so it must be intact
the issue with this is a
translation issue because kalima
doesn't just mean you know i'll say this
very clearly when it comes to allah and
he defines in the quran both places i'll
pull out the verses does not just mean
speech like words you write on a paper
kalima as allah mentions when he says
that jesus is like adam they are both
created from the word from the word of
god he said be and it is and he mentions
jesus is the word of god kalima
it's the it's talking about divine
decree
as allah
says word of god and that's why he ends
the verse off
with saying very clearly
that
no one
will help you or no one will be a refuge
for you against allah because as soon as
allah decrees something let's say allah
were to decree a punishment upon you and
no one can change that no one can take
it
so allah says being it is and it's a
decree so that's all it's talking about
no one can change the word of allah
meaning no one can change the decree
but even if you don't want to accept
that that very valid interpretation as
is defined in the quran by allah
the torah and the injil
as we have it today
is not what was originally sent so it
falls right there as well
does that make sense fired
no other way to put it bro no other way
to put it
allah does indeed write the scripture
sent before the torah the torah and
but that's not the old testament new
testament let alone the bible yeah 100
it's not bro it's been rewritten it's
been modified there's no way to know
yeah yes there are elements of it like
brother rami has said and we can
fact-check that with the quran
but it's not unchanged like the quran
100
so this is the message to young don if
you even want to make this kind of
argument
you have to substantiate it you have to
demonstrate how the bible has been
preserved
and the best way to do this
is to do it with someone who will try
and counter what you believe that's why
we've been inviting you onto our live
stream onto our channel so we can
discuss this
but regardless
let us get back to the video unless you
want to jump and say anything else
before we continue
yeah bro i just wanted to touch on the
point a lot of people have been
commenting on the on the live chat
whereas angel where's angel brother
angel is currently traveling right now
he's on the road
in france insha allah he will join us on
friday's live stream with brother comes
of zorces 6 p.m
all right inshallah a lot of people are
saying that don just scammed someone out
of 200 i don't know what that means
um and we shouldn't just claim things
about people please give more context
inshallah maybe we'll see it after the
stream but yeah i don't know about that
what i do know is a lot of people have
been saying that his thing with apost
did get a little heated because apos is
an atheist yeah yeah and he's trying to
spread the gospel according to him so
100 and see that's that's why i said
like you know he's he's an atheist he
doesn't even agree with him it's not
going to go in his favor i think you can
rewind i didn't say he's not going to go
in his favor but i said he's an atheist
doesn't even agree with him
so you can have fun with that i said
that and now people are saying that's
not going well is what it is let's get
back to uh the original we don't want to
take too long again the main purpose of
this is to invite don on friday's stream
where we will talk about the rest of his
claims we're only talking about the
things that he said in response to
what um we said on the stream with
shechman
that's it so i don't want to spend too
long watching everything there are just
a few things this is the same exact
argument that he makes
then he gets back and watches our
discussion
apologies guys a little laggy
let's just uh start from here actually i
have timestamps i think it's best that i
go off the timestamps
okay nevermind i don't have time stamps
and i'm cool with that because god plans
to proceed all god calls us to take up
her cross so if that's where it goes
that's where it goes but i'm not scared
and i'm not worried
he's talking about this comment like
wait till they catch you sleeping which
we're doing now and he's like
basically oh this is this is how muslims
react when they're on the back burner
so long story short he goes on this
tangent about bukhari you guys can watch
it um
he takes what shaykh ultimate said he
twists it
said that it's not coming from the
prophet so it's not he is not revelation
from allah
and uh he misconstrued that which is
funny but i'm not going to play it all i
want to get back to his actual arguments
against islam
because i think that's what we're all
here for
peace and blessings be upon him that i
hope that you will make the same exact
words against other traditions when i
bring them up
otherwise your sincerity will be
will be will be known to everybody sure
now
the age of
when we talk about this we know the
first thing that we'll have to discuss
it is not a fetal issue right and this
is for muslims to understand as well
it's not about that this is not about
our belief system
ooh but it is
it is here's what he's trying to say
right now wait let me finish the
sentence uh
because we can end the reaction after
this one sentence but because
he's lying
but we'll
keep it going still right
because earlier when i talked about the
differences in ages in the bible young
dawn and others were like well that
doesn't have anything to do with the
belief right it's funny that now
when i say that i i don't remember ever
capping for a dude sleeping with a
nine-year-old or anything under that i
don't remember ever saying that
that's not over that's not okay i don't
care who you bring up that's not okay
but
he moved on to let me say what i was
about to say because i thought he was
going to say more on it he was saying
it's not a creedal issue
oh
oh but it is
and here's why it is a creedal issue
so
let me find it let me find it
all right so here we got another
section from the quran right
uh
surah 33 ayah 21
there has certainly been for you hold on
let me move this there has certainly
been for you in the messenger of allah
an excellent pattern for anyone whose
hope is in allah and the last day and
who remembers a lot often let me break
that down for you for the people in the
back
[Music]
okay let me break it down for you guys
instead um
he actually has it right here so all
he's saying is that since the prophet
peace be upon him is a perfect uh role
model and excellent person for us to
follow and aisha said in hadith that
uh she was six uh when married and then
consummated at nine
that uh this kind of undermines
whichever man was saying al-shaykh man
was saying let me get back to this
screen here al-shaykh man was saying was
that
comes from allah with the quran or allah
through the prophet peace and blessings
be upon him that's all
allah
did not tell the prophet salam to say oh
she was nine when consummated and the
prophet peace be upon him himself didn't
say it so therefore it's not even on the
same level as revelation it was ashira
who said it that's not even denying that
she was
it's just playing that semantical game
that listen you want to say it's not
specifically in the bible well for us
it's not specifically in the hadith
because the hadith is something the
prophet peace be upon him said that's
what we consider a hadith
and the sunnah things he said and did
and so on and so forth so
again it's semantical it's not really
worth anyone's time
uh and again guys you know
okay guys let's not talk about any you
know oh he did this he did die he
scammed this let's inshallah let's just
wait for later
uh maybe when we have more evidence on
it again we don't want we don't hate
this guy right we don't want to
belittle him and and disrespect him and
call him a clown and
he can call us clowns all he wants he
can say we're liars we're deceivers who
cares let him say it man he's angry he
was emotional he was upset
yeah i would be too you know i would be
too if i was in that kind of position
may allah got him to islam
i mean bro i mean but i'm already
imagining you know that that one brother
that dm's us you gotta love for the sake
of allah and hate for the sake of allah
what do you say to that
i agree i agree and i hate the things
you say i hate the things that he's
saying but i'm not gonna go and hate him
at least not this early on you know like
maybe he's still on an emotional high
from what
what happened
people are saying he deleted the stream
but let's not talk about that let's get
back to the main
video here so i want to talk about a few
things inshaallah
i'm sorry guys i'm going to cut to it i
might not be able to play the clips
because i prepared this maybe like an
hour or two ago
but i do want to talk about some of the
points he makes you know what i'm just
he pulled out his powerpoint i'm going
to pull out my
my little document here i'm going to
show you guys a little teaser right now
[Laughter]
so basically
sheikh of man made the argument that in
the 6th century the average lifespan was
between 30 and 35. so what does he say
he says how old was the prophet when he
died how old was abu bakr when he died
how old was this person when they died
and he quotes a bunch of people who died
in their 60s and 50s and so on and so
forth which by the way isn't like it's
not like 80 80 years old to 100 years
old today
and the sad part about this is it's it's
almost as if he doesn't even realize
that this is an average for a reason
that you will have extremities the
average nowadays is maybe between 70 and
85 years
but do you have people that live to 102
years old
you have people that live to i think
how's the oldest lady that live fire do
you know
i think she was like hundred and thirty
something bro that's insane i wasn't
saying maybe 109 but if that's true
that's absolutely mad 121 something like
that yeah so are we gonna say that oh
the average life expectancy is no longer
uh no longer
uh 70 to 80 years old or whatever no
we're not going to say that
no
are we still live it's our stream ended
no we're still live
okay okay yeah we're still live scared
me bro so
let's look at the time of the prophet he
says oh the prophet died at this age
uthman at that age
at this age okay what about all the
children of the prophet it died before
30.
every single one of them how many did it
have sallallahu alaihi wasallam seven or
eight all of them musa ibn umer the
allah one who died before he was thirty
or maybe in his early thirties
i can quote and name all these people
that died at a young age
that doesn't change the fact that in the
sixth seventh century it was between 30
maybe 40 years old
but again khalas
that's a point another point what's
what's the depth what's the definition
of average bro
of a standard mean
it's not every case bro yeah
you know
one hundred percent one hundred percent
so type
moving on and for anyone who says that
oh you're gonna have you know that um
something like people who people who die
as babies you know it brings it back it
brings it down
how many people don't die as babies and
grow old older like the process set up
63 70 and die
and is it at least and not the very
least a good indicator of the lifespan
that average
they want to continue to make fallacious
arguments it's okay let's get back to
this trying to get the
the super chat back on the screen i'm
about to play don't worry i know i've
been stopping it a lot but um
and let me just pop it out let me just
remind you though all of those muslim
characters and biblical characters i
brought up that lived into their 50s 60s
70s 80s and 90s i guess they're all
genetic anomalies i was born this is the
time we're looking at
in that time period your average life
expenses he was 30 to 35 today it's
about 77 years of age in hong kong in
japan it's around 80.
okay
so today when we talk about the age of
marriage being 18 that would not be
practical for that time
today when we talk about oh
he's too young to get married she's too
young to get married what do we talk
about they haven't finished their
schooling
right she didn't finish high school she
didn't finish college he didn't get a
degree yet
understand in those times you didn't
have any of that so when a girl was
physically mature when when the
biological indicators were there for
example she got her period or you know
other signs that show maturity they
would get married because nature would
tell them you are now physically ready
to get married and that was very common
hold on
you believe because puberty has started
that that girl is ready to get married
and start having sex and start burying
children i just want to pause because if
you go back to the stream and actually
watch it which he doesn't even watch
anything close to the full thing
uh sheikh meant himself on the stream he
said let me pull up my camera here he
said what did he say
he said that there's multiple indicators
one of which is physical the other of
which is mental emotional so on and so
forth which means that no that's not the
only indicator and the scholars go in
depth and shechol mentioned that but
this is the problem
he makes a lot of mundane arguments and
and reductionist arguments based on one
point or even the tangent that we talk
about and he refutes that straw man or
that tangent and doesn't actually tackle
the real issue so that's what i want to
do today in sha'alami and fired are
going to clarify some of the
misconceptions and some of the logical
fallacies that he uses when he responds
to our points
[Music]
so if a girl is six
because there are genetic anomalies if a
six-year-old gets her period or a
five-year-old gets her period in fact
let's look it up
youngest
girl
to get her period she ends up being five
years old thought her bouquet
not a big deal
rests at two and started period at age
four now she's four being four so this
girl actually has some kind of medical
condition
however again this is irrelevant because
physicality is not the only thing that
determines whether someone's ready or
not so i don't know why he's going if we
have the argument that just because
something was normal or standard at a
time means it's morally correct is wrong
for it's funny because that's exactly
the argument he's using nowadays
he doesn't realize it i don't think i'm
going to play much more from his live
stream we're going to end it soon in sha
allah with um you know before a brief
reminder or after a brief reminder
but
what i do want to talk about
is someone saying raise my voice you
know i'll put my mic up hope that helps
inshallah what we do want to talk about
are some of the things that he mentioned
again that misconception so you can
watch the stream it's still up i just
made some side notes i don't want to go
on for three hours so i'm not gonna play
everything
he said that we cannot go based off
basically the majority but the reason
he's claiming what he's claiming is
because that is the majority today
it's called he's literally even
elaborating on the fallacy of presentism
here
the fallacy of presentism we mentioned
it and you brush it off what is it a
fallacy is something that is not
logically sound it's a skip a gap in
your logic that gets you to the wrong
conclusion so when he says oh they did
this x amount of years ago
we don't do that today
therefore it's wrong he doesn't think
that's what he's saying but that's
exactly what he's saying i'll explain
why
fayad
how many types of of of morality are
there
or what are the two types of morality
two bro it's objective morality and
subjective morals exactly what is what
is subjective morality
subject of morality is thinking that the
moral universe is something that i have
to agree with my interpretation of
what's right and wrong one hundred
percent it's as trivial as i like apples
fired like oranges
and the reason is because it's according
to yourself you cannot demonstrate which
one is true
which one is false which is moral which
is immoral and then there's objective
morality and the only way to achieve
objective morality or fully objectively
is from god himself because god is the
knower of all things so for him to make
this argument he has to one prove that
christianity is true and prove that the
bible goes back to jesus and then three
find within the bible something that
says that it's not moral
but what do you find
you find exactly what we go into
cases very clearly where it happened
in the bible and i'm not going to play
you guys can go and watch it he
mentions
if
rebecca was three and isaac was 40
which is one opinion of some jewish
scholars if that's the case isaac was a
nasty man that's what he said the
prophet isaac son of the prophet abraham
peace and blessings be upon both of them
he says was a nasty man and he gives
evidence that
apparently
abraham and other people disobeyed god
in the bible and they don't fully obey
god and so on and so forth i just want
to pull out one verse just one verse
look at this
he goes on to praise abraham so on and
so forth he says sojourn in this land he
says this to isaac by the way right this
is talking about isaac so journey in
this land and i will be with you and
bless you for to you and your offspring
i will give these lands i will establish
the oath that i swore to abraham your
father i will multiply your offspring
key point
as the stars of heaven and i will give
you a i will give to your offspring all
these lands and in your offspring all
the nations of the earth shall be
blessed because abraham this is the key
point obeyed my voice and kept my charge
my commandments my commandments
my statutes
and my laws meaning what
meaning what
abraham obeyed god how's he nasty man
and on top of that isaac what isaac
married one woman
rebecca
which means god is blessing him with
sons through rebecca
meaning he knows exactly what's
happening is he ignorant he's not he
knows exactly what's happening he didn't
say but wait till she's this year old
wait till this happens wait he just says
i will bless you that's it
so again he makes another
fallacious argument and another blunder
and fire don't worry i think what they
see on screen is uh sometimes different
from what from what you see because i'm
not always showing yeah same thing
they'll get clear as we go but fire bro
am i making sense or am i blundering
myself here what do you think
no you make sense bro i'll let you know
if i if i lose you i appreciate it but
if you guys made it this far come on now
download the adhan app what are you
doing if you're not
right you get you've got cable direction
you get prayer time reminders
any time you get to ramadan you know you
got the hajjan umar guide you know links
in the description download the addon up
and trust me i'm not i'm not just
vouching for this for any other reason
but i genuinely had wallahi allah as my
witness i've had it on that for like two
years now
ever since i've entered the app by
islamic finder ever since i downloaded
it bro i get that notification and if
you stack me on your prayers
you're going to feel some type of way
about looking at that notification and
then choosing to be like no i don't want
to pray anymore
trust me 100
if you're struggling with prayer
download it insha'allah make the effort
you will you will actually it gives you
a
direction gives everything you need to
know when to pray where to pray and
maybe even how to pray i didn't i don't
know if it goes that far but uh
definitely download the app it is
amazing even before you know youtube and
stuff i've been using it for years
one of the first things i downloaded as
a muslim somebody said that he already
debunked the three-year-old argument um
i watched the stream you can watch it
again yourself he doesn't debunk it he
just says that it's possible she was
three but some people say that she was
14 that's another opinion and you cannot
really prove one of the other because
it's not explicitly mentioned you can
try and deduce one of the other in
different ways but
regardless
he says if it is true then isaac's nasty
man i just explained why that makes no
sense and listen if that's not enough
for you let me give you something that's
at least a little more definitive
let's see here numbers 31 18. this comes
up a lot uh but i just want you guys to
pay attention to the hebrew
so it says
actually let me go back a verse so
there's a little more context
well it's not much better for the
christians but regardless now kill all
the boys and kill every woman who has
slept with a man
and then it says
but save for yourselves every girl who
has never slept with a man now you might
be thinking well that's not bad you know
it's not as bad as like you know doesn't
say she was x years old
so get this one only the young girls who
are virgins may live
notice it doesn't say young women it
says young girls now if that's not
enough let's go to the hebrew which is
the original language
let's go to the hebrew over here look
but all the young women this is the word
for young let's click on it and see what
it says
every time it's used every single time
it's used it's referring to little ones
or children look
according to their little ones here
translated as their families here
to uh to their little the girls
here it says for 31 18 the verse i just
quoted it says women children
specifically says women children
and then children little ones little
ones the little little ones little ones
little the children the children the
children every single time
every single time
are you gonna now renounce this
it's in numbers
let's be fair are you gonna announce
that
and the only thing that i'm not the only
thing but something else i'm actually
really mad about something that somebody
mentioned he insulted his own prophet
isaac peace and blessings be upon him
what is wrong with you why would you
insult the prophet of god this man is
better than you who are you
who are we compared to the prophets
honestly and for you to think that
you're better than him
because you believe jesus died for your
sins is honestly an abomination it's
egregious in all honesty and maybe bro
and it's not it's not just insulting his
prophet it's our prophet 100 and he
literally said i remember he said if he
actually did that he deserves to be hung
so
so
i want to put a challenge to young
actually i'll leave the challenges alone
the only challenge is
we invite you to come live with us on
friday like we mentioned i'm going to
leave it there there's many more things
i could say but um
i will i think i'll leave it there fight
if there's anything you want to add add
otherwise let's shout out the coming
livestream
oh yeah i was just going to say that bro
but if you want to shout it out shout
out bro let them know the time let them
know the details let them know the guest
and let them know to turn
notifications on and set it in the
calendar all right
one more time young dawn
no disrespect no hate not sitting here
calling you a clown or uh or this or
that or insulting we don't need to do
that we don't want to go back and forth
in videos and live streams we want to
have a nice respectful cohesive
conversation
it doesn't have to be a debate whatever
it can be a conversation
come on our stream
friday at what time fiat
6 pm eastern standard time that is 11
p.m uk time 6 pm est
join us and hamza zorces to talk about
other claims you made in that live
stream about the quran being
unscientific and so on and so forth this
is a respectful
invitation
we're not trying to set you up if you
fully believe what you claimed and made
your whole powerpoint based off of okay
come join us and talk to us we will give
you time to speak we can do five minutes
five minutes if you want
and if you really want me and fired will
just be hosts we'll just be moderators
and you can just talk to hums or sources
with that being said fayad please take
it away inshaallah before we end off the
stream
hello bless you all if you made it this
far comment down below hashtag science
because friday we are going to be
talking about science not science or
religion not science or islam
but the quran and science
100
if you send a super chat jazakallah my
apologies and rami's apologies if you
didn't uh you know we forgot to read it
or you know went away the chat is very
fast um we're a little old school aside
from that guys keep us in our duas uh
keep us in your duas you know like
comment subscribe help the algorithm and
insha allah we stay steadfast and keep
doing what we do in sha allah
and
in the name of uh not in the name of
because
it sounds like sadafi's don't come at me
but uh for the sake of after mentioning
super chats let me read one more
ganduria07 says dawn is in the state of
mind because sheikh man pulled a rug
from under him regarding his faith he's
just lashing out in sha allah got him i
mean i mean i believe honestly the same
thing
but with that being said again young don
hopefully we see you on friday
regardless we're still going to have the
live stream talk about what he said with
that being said allahumma
dunya
i